.
Amazon.com PETE'S NEW BOOK
JOINED US NOW WITH MORE FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN TULSI GABBARD IS
WITH US.
KELSEY I LOVE TO GET YOUR
REACTION TO JOE BIDEN'S REACTION
SAYING THAT THE MAGGOT CROWD IS
THE MOST EXTREME POLITICAL
ORGANIZER STATION THAT IS A
RECENT AMERICAN HISTORY BUT
START WITH ANTIFA THE GROUP BLM.
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT HOW DO YOU
REACT TO THAT BECAUSE THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY RIDICULOUS.
>> IT'S WERE SOME RIDICULOUS
SEAN, IT'S ABSOLUTELY DESPICABLE
AND OUTRAGEOUS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
CALLING MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ESSENTIALLY TERRORIST, PEOPLE
WHO POLITICALLY OPPOSE THEM ARE
VOTED AGAINST HIM HE'S CALLING
THEM TERRORISTS AN ATTEMPT TO
INTIMIDATE THEM INTO SILENCE AND
WE KNOW THAT THIS BECAUSE WE
HAVE HEARD THIS BEFORE FROM BOTH
HIM AND HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
YOUR MEMBER WHEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID ANYONE WHO
HOLDS EXTREMIST OR ANTIAUTHORITY
VIEWS WILL BE TARGETED FOR
INVESTIGATION AND POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION BY THEIR DOMESTIC
TERRORIST UNIT.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT
THIS QUOTE UNQUOTE MAGA CROWD IS
WORSE THAN TERRORIST, THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS SO FOR EVERY AMERICAN
WAS WATCHING, EVERY AMERICAN
WOULD SEEM THIS, NO MATTER HOW
YOU FEEL ABOUT THE MAGA CROWD
THIS IS AN AUTHORITARIAN ASSAULT
ON OUR FREEDOM, AND WE NEED TO
STAND TOGETHER VERY STRONGLY
AGAINST HIS ATTEMPT TO
INTIMIDATE AND SILENCE ANYONE
WHO HOLDS POLITICAL VIEWS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT FROM OR OPPOSED TO
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT AND HAS A
ADMINISTRATION ARE FURTHERING.
IT'S AN ASSAULT ON OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Hannity: WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE RUSH TO CLING TO
THIS POTENTIAL DECISION IN THE
SUPREME COURT WHICH WOULD OVER
RULE ROE V. WADE.
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTED SOMETHING
THAT --
IT'S INTERESTING THAT HE HAS
BEEN ASKED A QUESTION.
IT WILL BE RETURNED TO THE
STATES, ABORTION IS KNOCKING TO
BE UNAVAILABLE OR ILLEGAL IN
AMERICA SO THE DEMAGOGUE IN THAT
ISSUE I'M ARGUING THAT THE
REASON THAT THEY'RE DOING IT IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE THAT THEY CAN RUN ON AND
SAY HEY, WE DID THIS, THIS, AND
THIS.
AND WERE ALL BETTER OFF BECAUSE
OF IT IN MY WRONG?
>> I THING WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT EFFORTS TO ASSAULT OUR
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY, IT
CONTINUOUSLY POINTS TO THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF US, THEY ARE
AFRAID OF THIS QUESTION BEING
PUT TO THE PEOPLE THROUGH THEIR
STATE LEGISLATURES, THE PEOPLE'S
VOICES TO BE HEARD.
I THINK IT'S ALSO CRITICAL TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS LEAK IS A
VERY DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR
SUPREME COURT FOR THREE
IMPORTANT REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, FIRST OF ALL THIS
PERSON IS A THIEF WHO STOLE THIS
INFORMATION RELEASED IT WITH A
VERY SPECIFIC INTENT TO TRY TO
WHEN SENT PROTESTERS IN
INTIMIDATE AND PRESSURE ARE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES TO MAKE A
POLITICAL DECISION RATHER THAN A
DECISION OFF THE CONSTITUTION.
NUMBER TWO, THE FACT THAT
SUPREME COURT IS NOT IN PLACE TO
LEGISLATE FROM THE BENCH.
PUPILS WERE PRESENTED AS OUR
CHARGE TO MAKE LAWS, NOT THE
SUPREME COURT.
THEY NEED TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LASTLY
NEEDS TO GO AND PROSECUTE THIS
CRIME WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS TO MAKE AN EXAMPLE OUT OF OUT
OF THE PERSON WHO LEAKED THIS
INFORMATION BECAUSE OUR
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES CANNOT
OPERATE UNDER THE FEAR THEY WILL
HAVE PARTISAN POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS IN OUR HOUSE
INTIMIDATING AND THREATENING
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB
FOR THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Hannity: JUSTICE ALITO
SUPPOSED GIVE REMARKS AT A EVENT
HE HAD TO CANCEL A